welcome back this is the bench Bureau
show we're taking your emails in our
mailbag you can go to Delhi where I come
and subscribe be part of that mailbag
and we are also taking our calls at
eight five five two three six a thirty
to twenty eight Clint in some turkey
South Carolina you're on the bench Bo
struggle for Clint hey how you doing Ben
first like the humbly ask you to roll
them all over your arse during your
commentary because it is really funny
when you do it but uh my question is uh
I like you also think that Bernie
Sanders is generally bad for the country
at the top of a Democratic ticket and I
was wondering if you think has a
conservative slash Republican voting
tomorrow if voting for Biden would be a
good thing that you know boost his
numbers a little bit or voting at all
I'm just worried about it in general
yeah you know Clinton my general take on
this sort of stuff is I'm not a fan of
when Democrats try to vote in Republican
primaries and I'm not a fan of one
Republicans try to vote in Democratic
primaries I know there's all this sort
of strategic thought I know some of my
fellow hosts have encouraged for
Republicans to cross party lines and and
vote in open primaries my feeling is
that you're really playing with with the
monkey's paw that at a certain point
you're trying to wish somebody else into
the nomination and really you kind of
have to get out of the way and let the
Democrats choose who their who they're
gonna choose I could see a world in
which you know you going across party
lines in order to vote for a Biden and
Biden goes on to beat Trump and then you
regret it or you cross party lines in
order to vote for Sanders because you
think Sanders is more likely to lose to
trump and then Sanders beats Trump but
then you feel bad about it like I just
don't think that Republicans honestly
should be deciding who the Democratic
nominee is I think Democrats should
decide who the Democratic nominee is I
think open primary systems are idiotic
and so if I were you I'd frankly stay
out of it now you're in South Carolina
what's your feel down there for how
things are going well similarly I voted
for Obama back in six 2008 or and
obviously we see how that went but you
know I feel like this election is just a
little bit different considering who who
Bernie Sanders is and his ideologies and
obviously I don't want to make the same
mistake again but and you know like like
I said before along with you I think
he's just
candidate for our country yeah I totally
agree with you yeah I think he's a
disaster I just think that again better
news for for a public
- stay out of business that is not ours
and it is not our job to pick the
Democrats nominee for them Clint really
appreciate the call esra New York you're
on the venture fear I struggle for
newsroom hi Ben thank you so much for
taking my call how you doing today doing
well go for it sir I was wondering he
arrested be a better system in El
Escorial college system or popular vote
so I do like the Electoral College the
reason I like the Electoral College is
specifically because the American system
is a system that takes into account
states it takes into account localities
I think that the presidency has it's
becoming increasingly powerful the
Electoral College has become more and
more of an issue and more more powerful
I understand the case for a popular vote
system I really do every person's vote
counting exactly the same but the
reality is that one of the questions is
whether you believe that you would stay
in a system where you are perennially
doomed to lose and if you are in a
smaller state and you are never
campaigned to because you live in a
smaller state and everybody just hangs
out all the time in Boston New York LA
and Chicago then why would you consent
to be ruled by a group of people far
away from you for being pandered to by
politicians the Electoral College at
least makes Democrats and Republicans
run a sort of national campaign and take
into account interests that are not
going to be represented popularly maybe
as much as they should be in terms of
what is necessary to keep a democracy
going in order for a democracy or a
republic to continue people who lose an
election have to feel that the risks of
breaking away are greater than the risks
of staying and if you are constantly
losing elections because you're being
ignored I think that that actually
increases the risk that there's going to
be more of this tribalism and
polarization in American politics Ezra
alright thank you so much have a good
show me I really appreciate it
Brandon in Washington State you're on
the bench if you're a go for Brandon hey
thanks Ben for taking my call yeah big
Sam so my question is kind of about the
Medicare for All system that the
Democrats are kitchen you played the
clip from privilege of jaya paul the
other day where she stated that nobody
likes the health care but instead likes
their doctors as someone who likes my
health care and my doctors concerns me
that even though cited the other day
most people when asked about it can't
explain
and how it changes the health care in
this country there seems to be this kind
of insane amount of support for it from
the left do you think that this level of
ignorance about the supposing of
importance in this election because so
many people only seem to and are so used
to getting their information from the
news media who as we saw from the other
day with the David Wright thing
obviously Barry's stories or the truth
yep and gives it biased and muted
opinion of importance issues or are we
just so kind of numb to politics and the
like that people don't want to bother to
educate themselves anymore Brandon I
think that I think most people have not
taken a serious amount of time to study
politics I mean even top-rated shows
right the shows on Fox News may have 3.5
million viewers a night in a country of
330 million people I just don't think
people pay attention all that much to
this sort of stuff and when they hear
Medicare for all what they think that
means is a public option they think that
means okay I fell off of my medical
insurance and now I will be able to opt
into Medicare they think that it means
expansion of opportunities for people
who are lower down on the economic scale
they don't understand that what it means
is the abolition of private insurance
and when they're told that it means the
abolition of private insurance they're
not for Medicare for all this is the
case that people who judge has been
making and Amy Klobuchar have been
making the possibility of a public
option is a lot more popular than the
mandate of a public of a public mandate
now with that said even once people
understand what the public option is it
becomes a lot less popular the idea that
you are going to be subsidizing a
standard of care that eventually is
gonna run private insurance out of the
business and that is going to create an
incentive for employers to toss out your
private health care insurance and toss
you on to Medicare anyway like that
scares people people do not want to lose
their health insurance they shouldn't
want to lose their health insurance but
as far as people going along with the
story line or they just uneducated I
mean the answer is some of o'the if
you're uneducated you're more likely to
go along with the story line if you
don't know anything it's much easier to
buy into the line that's being sold to
you by the media Brandon really
appreciate the call Trevor in Colorado
you're on the bench Peter Lawford Trevor
quick back story I'm a vet and deal at
the VA on a regular basis last year I
felt a mass in my PEC you know on a
Schedule A cancer screening but the
soonest the VA could get me in was two
months out seeing as every day counts
early detection I found that
unacceptable one started calling local
scanning facilities once I found one
that accepted males I was able to pay
out of pocket and get scanned the next
day my question is do you see universal
health care operating in a similar
fashion as the current system for
veterans today 100% and it's one of the
reasons why and other people in Congress
who have been stumping to allow veterans
more options outside of the VA health
care system VA health care system is
good for what it's good for namely like
emergency care but and maybe for gradual
upkeep but for emergency situations
where you where you have a situation
like yours for for real disease
situations VA health care has been sadly
lacking obviously been seeing serious VA
problems for years on and Trevor really
thank you so much for what you do for
the country and obviously I think your
take on on the VA is exactly right and
I'm glad to hear that you're doing
better sir alrighty well tomorrow is the
South Carolina primary joe biden's
last-gasp or joe biden's big comeback we
are going to find out very shortly this
is the Ben Shapiro show